What is your advice to anyone who wants
to plan a road trip of their own?
Because you've got some really good takeaways.
All right.
First of all, and this is a small one
but so important, pack the right snacks, healthy snacks.
So you're not always tempted to pull off
and get fast food everywhere you go.
Keep them in the basket in the front seat.
So their arms reach.
Yeah, I totally hear you out.
Okay, is there any other tips you would give
about packing, mapping, having a plan,
being willing to let go of your plans?
So you know, actually one of the best things
about the van thing that's emerging,
the van scene that's emerging,
is that it actually forces you to Marie Kondo.
If I can turn that into a verb.
It really forces you to think about what you need.
You have, if this is a two person van
you bring two forks, two plates, you don't pack.
You don't over-pack you bring just what you need.
Our advice to people is to pack for a week long trip,
lay it all out on the floor,
take half of it, put it back away,
pack up the other half,
put it in your car or your van and just go.
You don't need it all.
As far as I'm concerned, Marie Kondo is a verb.
And I love that advice
because I don't know if it's a girl thing,
but I can totally be accused of over packing.
Oh yeah.
It happens.
Okay, so you and your family plan everything,
you take care of everything.
So we want to plan a trip for you
that you don't have to think about one thing.
Everything is dialed in.
You're gonna go to Aruba for a six night stay
at the Hilton Aruba, Caribbean resort and casino
and enjoy the best one happy island has to offer.
I'm talking crystal blue waters.
Who just, which that just sounds so good right now.
Warm tropical sun, famous palm trees on the beach.
And this time, you can fly.
(couple laughs)
I hope that's.
My back thanks you.
Okay, good.
So we're just taking care of everything.
Like the food, the amenities,
we're gonna dial it all in
and you just need to kick back, relax,
and I love this place because I think there's something
for adults and kids.
Kids don't want to be bored because it's too grown up
and grown ups don't want to just go
to kid places all the time.
So I think this place is a lovely hybrid.
Drew, I'm crying
Thank you.
Really?
Thank you so much.
We really need this.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh!
We thought this was kind of the prize,
because who doesn't want to drive it,
then, you know, do a road trip across the country.
This is incredible.
Thank you, Drew so much.
I want your toes in sand.
I want you to celebrate all you've accomplished as parents
and just the awesomeness that you brought to the show
and all the people that you were so kind enough
to deliver these Drew Gooder boxes
and join our local affiliates
and bring goodness literally across the country.
Oh, Drew, we would do it again in a heartbeat.
It was such an inspiring trip.
Funny you should say that.
I think we should do this again.
Yeah.
We would love to seriously.
In a heart beat.
Great.
If you're serious, we're in.
Season two coming up around the corner.
So relax.
Enjoy the summer.
Thank you.
Get your Aruba on.
And then let's talk about what we can do next.
Is it okay if we continue to sticker bomb in Aruba?
All I want you to do is sticker bomb
everywhere that you go.
And, can I also just take a ride?
Yeah!
Hop in.
Okay, good.
'Cause I've been, you know, looking at the van
and now I'm gonna ride in it.
I am in a Drew van officially.
(upbeat music plays)